look with no preseason
the the stakes are higher than ever
before you got to go right out of the
chute there's no ramp up there's no
gradual feeling out whether or not a
team's got it or not you are straight
out of the gate week one so today's
draft chris the players who most need to
get off to a hot and fast start in 2020
i've got the trivia question for you and
it goes a little something like this
it's inspired by baker mayfield by the
way so the question is who is the
brown's all-time leading passer in
yardage oh all-time leading passer and
yardage
i mean that's what i said i know well
you know i'm talking about i mean it's
one of those i want to say
i want to say you know bernie cosar
that's not my answer but that's where
you want to go
but i i don't know i got to think maybe
it might be um you know otto graham or
somebody like that in that era so i'm
going to go there i am gonna go there
and say otto
oh so close and so ridiculously close
and close within let me do the math here
very quickly if i can
129 yards away brian sipe oh
is the all-time
leading passer 1974 to 1983. he's got 23
713 graham had 23
584 baker mayfield already at number
nine on the all-time list it tells you
it tells you everything the game's a
little different about the history of
the quarterback position in cleveland
baker mayfield after two seasons is
number nine ahead of vinnie testaverdi
and derek anderson so i get to brian see
i got my notes here
i look they're all obviously everybody
needs to get off to a hot start i i've
got to go with
and i'm sorry chris
i'm taking your guy
but aaron rodgers
must get off
the to the start of the 2020 season
quickly and definitively and with a
middle finger to the organization for
trading up to draft a quarterback in
round one aaron rodgers needs to prove
that he's still the guy he was last year
if not better we're gonna talk about the
motivation and how he's gonna yeah you
gotta show it right out of the gates
when they go to minnesota week one and
the good news is he won't have to worry
about any fans there to make it too loud
for him to operate well i i i know what
you're saying i mean i i get it um but i
mean where i i'd push back is
public perceptions not against aaron
rodgers quite yet like i think he'll get
a little leeway if he didn't get up to a
hot start and
you know talking to some people who know
some things up in green bay i'll just
say this you know i i
from what i've heard to this point you
know it's been made very clear that
jordan love is very raw very raw he is
in no you know nowhere near threatening
aaron rodgers at least this year so i
i've heard that's kind of off the table
but i get what you're saying i am going
to push back a little bit because i want
to win the trap and screw you okay right
who cares look who cares about that
let's make points that people can get
their arms around the idea that if he
stumbles out of the gates what's that
going to do what's that going to spark
what are people going to start saying
they're going to say put in jordan love
now no he's going to be like well maybe
they knew what they were doing well
maybe maybe next year is the year you
know that kind of thing i know you're
right you're right but they should be
saying whoa i mean could they get some
talent around the guy um all right i
don't even know where i want to go with
this one first here i'm going to go with
le'veon bell i'm going to go with
le'veon bell i think that's a bullseye
on him this year i mean there's been a
lot of talk about that contract and what
he's doing and maybe trading them and
everything like that command this guy
was one of the best players in football
before he held out for the contract
issue in pittsburgh that one year and to
me yeah he's kind of you know falling
off the radar that way you know and does
he still have it you know i think him
getting off to a good start you know
forwarding with some hundred yard
rushing games getting the ball in the
pass game all that will back people off
of him here in new york because right
now
jets fans have a bad taste in their
mouth about le'veon bell he's the last
regime signing you know and we've heard
they were a little angry about what they
paid for le'veon bell and they got duped
and all those type of things so i'm
gonna throw le'veon bell out there
yeah and remember and we made this point
previously le'veon bell a great running
back is not the guy that you make the
starting point for an offense he's the
icing on the cake you need the offensive
line you need the passing game you're
not going to get high-end performance
out of a great running back if you don't
have the rest of an offense around him
so maybe the rest of the offense will be
good enough that they can get more out
of le'veon bell maybe he can have the
kind of start this year that quiets that
talk because if he doesn't have a great
start chris the same thing's going to
happen this year that happened last year
teams are going to call about trading
form it's going to be cheaper and easier
to trade for them this year because this
is the final year of fully guaranteed
money in his contract it was 26 million
paid out over the first two years i
believe 26 or 27 you don't have that
obligation of fully guaranteed money
next year
so if there is a stumble if there is a
slow start if the jets struggle he's
going to be one of those guys that may
end up with another team by the time
it's all said and done all right next
one for me i'm surprised you know this
is one that i think
um you know i had to really really scan
through all the teams and really think
about it but i think this one could have
been my first pick and maybe it would
have been if you had won the the the
rights to the first selection and taking
aaron rodgers ryan tannehill
he's got to have a he he look too many
questions still linger about this guy
who got a gigantic contract after coming
in
halfway through the season taking over
from marcus mariota getting the team to
the afc championship game if he reverts
to the worst of what we saw from him
when he was in miami or if he should get
injured early on which would fulfill a
narrative that continues to hover around
him
they're going to be saying man they
wasted their money on ryan tanil he's
got to start earning that money and
proving the titans right right out of
the gates in 2020 yeah oh i i don't
disagree with you i mean that stigma's
there you know we're gonna
talk about that story and people don't
ever let it go oh he was a top 10 pick
what did he do with the miami dolphins
and you know because he's kind of a
quiet humble guy too who's not gonna
like you know tell reporters for lack of
a better phrase to shut up and i'm doing
this or whatever else
yeah people want to jump on him
definitely but uh i i don't i don't
expect it to change a whole lot from
last year i think this is a time where a
guy made the you know met the perfect
team the perfect scheme around him and
it's showing all his ability you know at
its finest and uh i expect him but
you're right there's going to be that
talk why do they ever pay ryan 10 and
hold that what did he ever do in miami
well he was actually really good at
miami stop blaming one guy for an issue
of the whole organization
okay
okay i'm i'm i mean i gotta go with
tyrod taylor that's where i'm going to
go he's got to get off to a hot start i
mean i watched hard knocks last night
they're already talking about justin
herbert and with the chargers and you
know he's one of those guys again you
just watch him they had a little segment
last night all the players going man
herbert i like your you know i like your
ball i like the way it comes in all that
sounds weird saying that they actually
even joked about that on the show but
then they show them throwing the ball
into nets and things like that i mean
the guy's got a special talent and we
know you know this chargers team's got
some talent if tyrod taylor and the
offense are kind of floundering early on
and maybe they're only you know two and
two or two and three out of the gate he
could be in trouble and they go with
justin erbert
you know i can go a lot of different
directions here um
i i'm you know what we talked earlier in
the show about a running back in a
contract year in alvin kamara another
running back in a contract year that
flashed early and tailed off last year
and this is a big year for him james
connor steelers running back right he's
kind of falling off the radar screen
definitely from the standpoint of
thinking of him as a as a above average
running back and i i think that that if
he's not getting it done early this year
they're gonna give those carries to
somebody else so you know to establish
himself
as a long-term member of the steelers
organization to get that second contract
and defend off any challengers he needs
to get off to a big start for the
pittsburgh steelers yeah i i like that
that's your best pick so far finally you
know third time's a charm for you um but
but yes
it's been underwhelming he definitely
did not replace le'veon bell and what
they missed there and if he doesn't get
off to a hot start that benny snell that
anthony mcfarlane from from maryland
they're gonna take over his carry so i'm
with you there i like that pick all the
way okay
um
i gotta go i'm gonna go back to the
running back well i'm david johnson you
know we talked about them when we just
did the state of the franchise of the
houston texans come on i mean has there
been a trade you know
more made fun of this off season than
that you know everybody looks at that
and just goes man you gave deandre
hopkins away for david johnson and
you're paying david johnson 10 million
million dollars i mean billy o'brien is
never going to hear the end of that if
david johnson has some underwhelming
stat lines you know the first three or
four games of the year uh so that is one
i look at just to get you know the
public perception change and everybody
off billy o'brien the gm's back and all
those things where um i i certainly
think david johnson needs to make his
his his part in the offense known early
on
he's got to reestablish himself that's
right other names i had on my list todd
gurley ben roethlisberger dalvin cook
who's trying to get that new contract in
minnesota trying to put pressure on the
team to get it and derek carr yeah derek
carr okay he's tired of being
disrespected got to come out and play
better just like lincoln kennedy said
play better and you won't be
disrespected
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports